[Music]
chicago for my first
beautiful north american burger outside
of vegas because of the the vibrance
this city has to offer i've loved the
foodie culture here i fell in love with
chicago literally 15 years ago there's
something quite energizing about
the buzz the foodie culture but also
it's a very hot scene everywhere i go
around the world everyone's talking
about what's coming out in the midwest
what's happening in chicago so
i want to be part of that scene and i
can't think of a better city right now
than chicago the dna of flavor
that beautiful blend from the chuck
to the brisket to the foreign even down
to that basting of that amazing pate
with the worcestershire butter
so we pride ourselves on great flavor
from the amazing fries to great burgers
to great shakes but i promise you it's
gonna become one of the best burgers
you've ever eaten
a delicious next level burger baste
aioli
patty
wagyu
watercress cheese
truffle
serve
and that's how you make a delicious next
level burger
[Music]
my man
5 million subscribers oh man
congratulations we good happy new year
good to see you my man thank you please
oh my god
stop
oh my goodness man
come on guys seriously thank you so much
[Music]
at six foot two from scotland united
kingdom the master of the kitchen
number three
gordon
ramsay my god come on
benny
seriously
come on man
amazing bud good to see you man oh my
goodness me
wow come on
what an amazing arena good job bud
uh seriously amazing
oh no oh no
oh my god honestly benny we should give
us some tips please
oh my god so you're the choose you want
to do half court shots
do you want to keep it simple no
just give me some tips sir some tips
please
for next please
i just just show you just show me please
thank you
oh my god
no no ben no no
no showing off is this the three pointer
line is this from this far back
look at look at that look at the
distance of that thing thank you sir
thank you
man right get your [ __ ] together come on
fine one more dress one more just please
come on kid come on
oh that was him
no stop does someone really do it from
the halfway line
stop it
[ __ ]
backwards
oh there's no there's no there's no way
that's the trick backwards
benny stop it
ready
oh bollocks one more ben one more ben
i can't believe that people really get
that in there do they
oh yes
here we go
right come on
man
[Music]
why do they make you look so easy thank
you
huh
i can't be the only one saying that can
i